I
hey guys Peter Brown here I'm with Scott
Butterworth who just got a chance to
look at the latest version of Star Fox
for wii u scott i played this back at e3
and i walked away a little bit
unimpressed because nintendo put a lot
of effort into making sure that the
gamepad was utilized to his full extent
and in doing so I kind of divided up the
game a bit like I had to aim with the
gamepad but I could only see where my
ship was going if I looked up at the
television and that created a really odd
experience for me where I felt like one
it wasn't as traditional star fox as the
game looked and to the controls weren't
intuitive enough for me to just jump
right in I'm curious how your experience
was playing as you build I think I'm
feeling maybe a little more optimistic
because I can kind of see where they're
going with it the controls still
function largely the same way I mean it
is still that split you know cockpit
view on one screen and third-person
perspective on the other screen you can
now switch which screen displays which
display so if you want your cockpit view
up on the TV you can do that you can
actually swap so whatever feels more
intuitive to you but yeah ultimately you
are still trying to dart your eyes
between two separate screens in an
effort to kind of get a better idea of
what's actually happening in the game I
do get what they're going for I mean
like if anybody who's played in
traditional starfox game knows that if
you're trying to like shoot a turret on
the ground for example you're also going
to be kind of flying into the ground in
the process because you can only shoot
where your ship is pointed so I think
divorcing those two things allowing your
ship to fly in one direction while you
aim in another direction fundamentally
makes a lot of sense
and in fact almost creates a layer of
skill that that wasn't there before the
only issue is it kind of works better on
paper than it does in practice and I
think that may just reflect the fact
that neither of us had a truly
substantial amount of time to play the
game to really adjust to what's altima
tlie a very new approach to this kind of
game so I'm hoping that with time that
idea will pay off because again I think
the idea is good when I played starfox
for Wii U I didn't notice that the level
design had benefited in any way from the
ability for you to look around while
you're shooting for example sure like it
didn't seem to allow tan intend or
platinum in this case to make the levels
any more different it still looked like
the old starfox levels just with this
added layer that I wasn't used to did
you notice anything where it felt like
this aspect of this level is only
possible now that they've made these
changes clearly certain boss encounters
in particular are designed with this
dual screen approach in mind one of the
alternate routes that you can find leads
to a boss encounter that has you in all
range mode and have to shoot a bunch of
like spider robots off of a tower and
the way that you approach them it
actually makes more sense to sort of be
looking at the screen so you can aim
precisely and shoot down on top of them
is the thing like they're weak point is
on the top of their body so you have to
kind of like fly over them and shoot
down directly on top of them so clearly
that enemy was designed to capitalize on
this particular approach to the gameplay
so they I think they were mine to live
in and I would hope that as you play
you'll find more instances like that
so I think the starfox game that people
want is it's in Star Fox zero somewhere
it's just hopefully we'll be able to
like dig past that initial layer of
potential frustration and learn to it
sort of embrace and enjoy this more sort
of nuanced and demanding gameplay and
once we're able to embrace that we'll be
able to truly enjoy all of the you know
long-standing aspects that of the series
that we've always loved I hope you're
right we'll know in a few weeks starfox
for Wii U comes out in April
you
you